Netflix lets you revel in the good, the bad,
and the downright weird, all from the comfort
of your living room.
It's a great place to binge watch your favorite
shows — but it's also a vast repository
of fantastic movies...if you know how to find
them.
Wading through Netflix's recommendations can
be a daunting task, so we rounded up some
of the best hidden gems on Netflix for your
viewing pleasure.
Turbo Kid
What happens when you roll every post-apocalyptic
trope into one movie, mix in absurd violence
straight from Quentin Tarantino's dreams,
and then add superheroes?
Probably something like Turbo Kid, a movie
that plays like Mad Max if the production
crew could only afford bicycles.
Stay with us here.
It's got wastelands, a water war, robots,
Soylent Green jokes, and an evil Michael Ironside
— which, everyone knows, is the best kind
of Michael Ironside.
Remember this?
“Alright.
We’re gonna do it the scanner way.
I’m gonna suck your brain dry.”
Imagine that, but with an eyepatch and less
hair.
In the distant future of 1997, a loner kid
survives one day at a time in a wasteland,
scavenging junk to trade for water.
To pass the time, he reads the adventures
of Turbo Rider, a superhero with a blaster
cannon on his arm.
But when he gets on the wrong side of the
local warlord, he has to become the hero himself
to save his new friend.
Don't expect any deep insights into human
nature with Turbo Kid.
Just enjoy it for what it is: a goofy romp
through the imagination of someone who probably
grew up wearing out the scanlines on their
RoboCop LaserDisc.
I Don't Feel at Home in This World Anymore
Call him Frodo all you want, but Elijah Wood
is working hard to reinvent his image as an
actor, and we can totally respect that.
From his mannequin-obsessed killer in 2012's
Maniac to his dirty cop con man in 2016's
The Trust, Wood is clearly capable of branching
out.
In I Don't Feel at Home in This World Anymore,
Wood plays a geeky loner who teams up with
a woman in his neighborhood to find the people
who robbed her house.
Don't let the title bog you down.
It's a black comedy in the vein of the Coen
brothers' Fargo and Burn After Reading, a
subtle, escalating thriller about two everyday
people thrust over their heads into a world
of crime where anything can — and does — go
wrong.
I Don't Feel at Home in This World Anymore
is moody, occasionally hilarious, and surprisingly
poignant.
“I’m not letting you shoot anyone.
Anyone else.”
Makkhi
If you've never watched much Bollywood, it
may be hard to tell if Makkhi is making fun
of those films or comfortably nestled at the
heart of it all.
The absurdity feels intentionally cranked
to 11, but then again, there's also a distinct
possibility that a song-and-dance number followed
by a Rocky training montage for a reincarnated
fly is completely normal.
Either way, it's totally worth your time to
watch.
Here's the premise, and it's a doozy: A fly
born from the soul of a dead man goes on a
revenge rampage against the guy who killed
him.
It's John Wick crossed with A Bug's Life crossed
with…uhhh...La-La-Land?
Maybe?
There's a trippy Ant-Man vibe to the visuals
and explosive action sequences, all tied into
a deathmatch between a man and, well, a housefly.
As far as hidden gems go, this one's like
stumbling across a dead unicorn in the woods.
It's majestic.
And you just don't know what the hell to do
with it.
Harlock: Space Pirate
From the outset, you can look at Harlock:
Space Pirate and expect a rocket-fueled amount
of fun.
After all, a movie with the gumption to call
itself exactly what it is in the title isn't
about to bore you with over-long, tedious
insights into the internal struggles of being
a space pirate.
No, you're getting spaceships, laser bombs,
robot suits, and — in case you missed it
the first time — space pirates.
Based on a Japanese manga, Harlock: Space
Pirate was well-received on its release in
2013 and even won Best International Animated
Feature at the 3D Creative Arts Awards.
But the CG spectacle didn't come anywhere
close to making back its production budget
and ultimately failed to find much of an audience.
Does that mean you should steer clear of Harlock?
Not even close.
If the geek pleasure centers of your brain
light up at the thought of a well-made, beautifully
animated sci-fi adventure, you'll definitely
get a kick out of Harlock: Space Pirate.
The Beaver
Mel Gibson had a rough couple years in the
mid-aughts, and although he's now got another
Oscar-winning film under his belt, his return
to Hollywood didn't come without a few false
starts.
In 2011, he starred in Jodie Foster's film
The Beaver as Walter Black, the CEO of a toy
company who has a nervous breakdown, loses
his family, and tries to hang himself from
a hotel shower curtain.
On the edge of death, Black snaps completely
— and allows his life to be taken over by
a beaver puppet.
“I love you.
I’m the only one that really, really loves
you.”
It's technically a comedy, but dark doesn't
come close to describing the humor.
This is blacker than a coal mine after a cave-in,
an intimate portrait of depression and mental
illness that flows so seamlessly from Gibson's
acting that you can't help but believe he's
channeling his own personal experiences.
With incredible supporting performances from
Jodie Foster, Anton Yelchin, and Jennifer
Lawrence, The Beaver is definitely a hidden
gem worth watching, if only once.
Although afterward you may need to watch something
a little more light-hearted.
Like The Human Centipede.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!